okay now we have Martin from picnic he's
going to talk about about multimodal
product demand forecasting so basically
how your food gets to your house from
the internet let's give a warm welcome
to
[Applause]
Martin good morning everybody yeah yeah
bringing food from the internet to your
house that's a very good description of
what we do uh maybe to start who I am so
my name is Mara I'm working at picnic
Technologies as a data scientist where I
mostly work on uh yeah the M forecasting
of Articles at a large scale and I'm
also a researcher uh at the University
of Amsterdam where I work with
multimodel machine learning so maybe the
topic of this talk might not come as a
surprise telling my background um it's
the multimodel product demand
forecasting um so what that exactly is I
will explain later but basically using
the pixels on your screen to better
predict the amount of our articles which
might seem a bit far-fetched than it is
but it actually works so that's already
a small sneak peek to the end of the
presentation um so what you will be
learning today is well how we do article
demand forecasting at picnic which is uh
quite interesting but also uh for
everybody uh in the corner there is a
EPV and what that stands for you might
hear later or have to find out yourself
and you can win a Lego version of that
if you go there and I also will be
encouraging you all to do groceries at
picnic because who's already doing their
groceries with
picnic and who's not
ah boo I will convince you um and last
but not least uh I will be teaching you
how you can use a picture and a
description of a potato to make better
demand forecast and hopefully that will
be also interesting for other types of
task as
well so what does picnic do for
everybody that's not yet a customer we
bring groceries to your doorstep for
free whilst being sustainable and
reducing waste so make sure to uh sign
up because that's all I think pretty
nice
things and how we do this is basically
uh well we don't have any brick and
mortar stores that's we need those we
actually straight from the farm try to
bring the products as fast as possible
to your house uh using using these uh
Vehicles so if we have a potato it goes
through from the Farmland through your
house as fast as possible this was the
only animation I put in the slides so I
hope you enjoy
it um the nice thing about working at
picnic is yeah it's also a bit of a
recruitment talk of course so we build
everything inh house so the software the
app of course because the app is the
only interface we have with our
customers except from the runners
bringing stuff to your uh house um but
also the hardware so even the vehicles
we design ourselves in house so we go
pretty far with that but of course as a
data scientist um we also buildt the
algorithms inous and we have quite a lot
of them
actually um so of course we have the the
product recommendations in the app
making sure that people can find the
things they want to buy quickly um we
have customer success models so that's a
lot of NOP trying to get the the
questions to the right people as fast as
possible um we have a lot of routing
since we have vehicles that have to go
to houses well you can figure that one
out I guess uh very important to do
correctly and today we're going to talk
more in the supply chain corner so
that's the article demand forecasting
but of course we do a lot of forecasting
because it's very important for us uh to
know what's coming up and about I I
think we have about 26 uh models running
in production supporting our whole
operation that's important if you want
to win the Lego e By the
way but today we're going to be talking
about the article demand forecasting uh
so you see these nice products that we
sell basically the article demand
forecasting is for well months ahead
days ahead uh predicting how much of
these we were going to be
selling and for some products it's quite
easy because people with us we don't
deliver within 10 minutes we actually
deliver the next day so if you decide to
sign up for picnic which I can truly
encourage you to do so um you can order
bread for tomorrow and well the moment
we start baking it we already know how
much we have to make so that's a quite
easy task if you're a data scientist
because we already know what we have to
do but there's also products that we
don't bake ourselves because it's pretty
hard to bake a melon um so we get them
from suppliers so we need to know a few
weeks in advance like how much we're
going to be ordering if 's a promotion
maybe we need to order a lot more than
normal um so really need to get that
correct and I might say this is one of
the most uh healthy slides you will see
today if if I'm maybe
right um but for some products we also
have like a constant feed like a
real-time rolling forecast with how much
product we'll be selling uh that's sent
to our suppliers so they can on their
side they can well basically optimize
their operations so here you can see
four mangoes and then I accidentally
leave that this slice in from karaoke T
night we'll guess the reference a few
people I
see okay back to the serious part um so
the accurate forecasting uh that we do
uh is essential to balance waste and
unavailability if we uh forecast too
much we have waste this is something we
really is at the core of our company to
prevent um but at the same time if we
forecast too little we will have
unavailability and our customers will
maybe uh go somewhere else for their
products because we don't have them so
that's very uh we have to be very good
at forecasting and this is why we go
pretty far with that so next up I have
six potatoes and seven facts about
article demand forecasting at picnic I
will go through them quickly but to give
a bit of a setup why we went into the
whole multimodel part of
it uh we use uh snowflake as our data
warehouse basically which is very nice
we have about 15 data Engineers working
on that non-stop to get us very high
quality of data um almost real time even
we have a team of 12 data scientists
what we call full stack data scientists
so actually with a software engineering
and more mathematical background over
150 analysts that really help us out
with finding the right features Etc
things like this uh some of them even
build models themselves we have one of
them here today and we have hundreds of
operators that are for example in the
inbound system uh that we have adjusting
uh predictions to see if they're correct
so yeah sort the human Loop part human
in the loop part of it um so we're
active in three markets right now France
Germany and the Netherlands we we
skipped Belgium but I did a little bit
of slight magic to hide that
fact um so for all these markets we have
about 10,000 articles give or take um
which we are trying to order fully
automatically but also have humans in
the loop so these are these
operators um so this amounts to hundreds
of millions of predictions every day um
with a variety of models and decision
logic all combined together um yeah so
this is a bit of an overview I will get
back to that
later and yeah we serve this all on
kubernetes and we have Arco to set our
jobs up so depending on the type of
model the freshness of the model we can
all really orchestrate it really nicely
and the nice thing about you also see
the picnic logo here this is because we
have a lot of In-House uh python
packages that we use um from things like
connecting to your database to also even
like model performance monitor tools
that we made
inhouse and another nice thing that we
have is automatic retraining uh with GPU
enabled cumes nodes which is very nice
so we can just schedule retraining as
much as we want and it will all skill
yeah until we basically spend way too
much
money um we have also have Pandera which
I can really recommend to look into for
data sanity checks it really helped us a
lot um so really use that that if you
want to well well find uh issues before
the issues find you um ml flow also very
nice to keep a nice structured way of
locking all your model training runs
yeah Nidia and pytorch I think at it V
you don't not really need an explanation
but we do use
them um other things we use for the
continuous alerting um is data do which
is more on the surface side but also
very nice to know when your models are
not running anymore because no
prediction is often even worse than a
bad
prediction um and everything is always
linked to slack which is very nice
because then we can actually well send
messages forward to people like hey the
model trained very well this week you
can click here to a dashboard for more
insights
Etc so very quickly some facts um so I'm
not going to be talking about all the
models that we have I'm going to be
zooming into to one particular model
that we're using and that's the temporal
Fusion Transformer uh my colleague
Sharon last year gave a talk about this
one so you can look that up I can really
recommend that if you want to know more
about the the nitty-gritty details of it
um but basically it's uh yeah it's a
very nice Implement model made by Google
with a nice implementation well nice
it's a it's an implementation in py
forecasting uh and it's very versatile
there's a lot of different type of
features you can put in there and it's
very good at a lot of forecasting
tests so of course uh one of the things
we put in there is tab input so you can
think about product categories holidays
historical demand vacation period
uh the weather promotion recipes well
it's all very important works very well
but there is an issue if you use only
this type of
information and this a picture of Pluto
because I'm talking about the data drift
and the changing of categories I'm not
going to explain the reference but I
think it speaks for itself um what
happens with our products is that they
move around in categories a lot for
example if you have a nice nice steak
normally it would be considered meat
during Christmas it's like a nice
Christmas article it moves around in the
data um which you can of course adjust
for but there's always weird things that
will happen with these type of
categories in tabular data that in your
test setup will work perfectly fine but
the moment you go to production they
change a lot and well there will be a of
drift
happening um and then we also have the
cool start problem since we constantly
are expanding into new markets and
launching new assortments um well we
don't have any historical demand so good
luck with your
forecasting um and also the real changes
as we all might know during Co Etc that
this is uh ongoing we don't know what's
going to happen next but it's hard to
train for
it so recently the the the new Power of
Transformers has been Unleashed on us uh
I used this picture at the beginning I
think it's me but then slightly more
presidential it's a completely synthetic
picture uh that what this we all know
the Pope in the puffer jacket and this
is also a generated Tree on a website I
made generated tree for free.com it does
nothing but when you go there it will
generate a fake tree
um the these are all very nice and fun
um but we were thinking can't we use
Transformers for a more sustainable
Planet uh so it really aligns with the
keynote this
morning and I think it's possible and
why not take it a step further and take
pictures of a potato to make a more
sustainable Planet which is actually
possible um so if you think of it
because all the decisions that our
customers made are in their brain and
based on what we serve them in our
application these are just pictures of
products and descriptions of products
and they use this to decide if they want
something so predicting the demand that
we want to predict as well so would it
not be possible based on a picture to
think hey where is this going to sell
and how much is this going to
sell um so an example of this is for
example uh can of Bavaria this is
probably going to be easier for Dutch
people you can sort of assess where in
the country this is going to sell and
that is going to sell a lot during
Carnival for example uh something like
goals is going to sell a lot in a
different part of the country and a lot
during start to cross for who gets the
reference this will really kick off and
this is yeah well probably will sell a
lot in Amsterdam and in rdam it will be
less popular um can recommend the beer
it's a very local product and this is
all just based on the images so let
alone if you add the text so this is uh
this is not based on our customer data
this a bit like my gut feeling this is
our areas where the products will sell
more um so combining this all this is
what brings us to the multimodel
temporal Fusion Transformer um basically
we're fusing this all together to make
better
predictions so the the past input uh I
already talked about then we of course
we have the future known inputs so this
like weather forecast or the confirmed
demand we already have uh these go into
the model but what I will be zooming in
now is like how would you extract Visual
and textual features to also feed them
into this forecasting
model starting with the textural uh
embedding uh yeah using the Ste Birds
it's already a bit old school but I
think it's still a very nice model for
techniques like this uh basically what
we did here is add an additional layer
on the end uh make it linear so we can
know basically extract embeddings from
it and then we train them on product
text like this so you see for example
see the pumpkin cubes uh where in the
text you can already see some hints like
in what season what events might it
seill so I was thinking if you can get
that into an abing it will help the
forecast so this is a translation by the
way C so there is some typos in it
probably GPT or something it it was
GPT um but the information is in there
so what we did here is the uh trained
the the still birt model with some
frozen layers uh on these text with uh
well with the text uh descriptions and
ingredients as input and have like the
average demand for a product as the the
target of it and like that we sort of
like fine-tuned the model for this
particular Tas can be done in a lot of
different ways but I would say this was
uh how we tried it for this
experiment and then we also have the the
visual embedding uh for that we would
use the resnet which is I think almost
historical but uh very uh well you know
what you get and it works how you want
basically we did the same thing there so
we gave uh product images as input and
we had a last layer with like a bit
reduced a lot of reduced dimensionality
going from about 2,000 to to about 30 uh
in size and find you it on the average
demand per product as well to be able to
turn these pictures into an
embedding and well we do some I would
say more categorical categorical type of
uh geographical features as well but in
order to also really combine the
geographical aspect of these products
their month with um the nice fancy
features from the visual and textual
side we also used the uh geographical
embedding for which we create a graph so
the per purple square blocks you see uh
those are like the warehouses that were
the granularity that we're demanding
predicting demand for and the greens
ones are all the hubs and this is only a
few of them because else the picture got
very cluttered but it got a bit of an ID
uh we turn that in made turn that into a
graph and using no toac um which you can
look up is a very nice model to just
turn any graph into some sort of uh
embedding uh we actually get some of
like a geographical embedding which will
allow to very precisely understand like
in what type of areas will there be
delivered so yeah then we're going to
the nice part the evaluation of this
all um so we're predicting at a very low
granularity especially I think uh after
the talk before this is nice to mention
so it's for all our articles for all
warehouses for specific days and
specific slot picking
groups um so when talking about eval
ation I always like to mention uh
evaluation metrics are like sheep
they're happiest in large groups so I
would always advise on using as much as
possible and showing as much as possible
um and also use them on different
subsets so you can really see what's
happening here um but that's my advice
now from the next uh pictures I will
table I will go into way using W only so
I'm throwing my own advice away um and
also with evaluation of course it's good
to also just look at your predictions
and actuals like at the lowest possible
uh level what we do here so for the
pumpkin cubes uh mentioned earlier you
can see all the different well it's like
combinations of these models so I'm not
sure if you can see it here but the
purple line is the the text and the go M
uh multimodel temporal Fusion
Transformer um and here you don't really
see the Improvement but overall there is
actually so looking at wpe um adding
this type of multimodel features really
puts the dent into the the predictions
we make and these experiments were done
on a very small data set with only 50
million row or something and you could
see a big Improvement and the
Improvement seems to be even more the
further ahead we predict which makes
sense because uh well for the next few
days we already have a lot of confirmed
demand so the model tends to behave
quite
differently and what is fun is when you
take like different subsets so that's
advice I am following myself uh you can
see that for some categories like adding
the Geo information re really works well
uh and adding the text might even
decrease performance a bit so it does
show that we're not uh we still need to
do a lot of tweaking to the model which
I think is uh is still possible um but
overall adding different type of
modalities really can improve the
forecasting
task and uh this is uh I think nice is
the the w w some people say for delivery
date uh during Christmas uh
2022 and where you can really see the 25
26 so that first the second day of
Christmas uh as you can see it puts a
really big dent and this is I believe
personally um because of although how
many categories change there
Etc but that's also one of our most busy
days so this really makes people on our
business side very happy to see when we
can improve the model
there so um I hope you learned how to
use pictures of a potato and
descriptions of a potato to achieve more
stable predictions maybe it inspires you
to also look into uh yeah more
multimodel approaches for other type of
projects uh also want to mention we have
some very nice discounts this week uh so
beers the second one 50% off and also
for your breakfast cereal as well so
before and after your P data conference
you can come to us and of course we are
hiring we're hiring a lot python
developers data Engineers data
scientists and mlops Engineers you want
to know uh why we use these different
names come visit us at the boot in the
corner please and you can also win this
very cute custom Electric Picnic vehicle
which is also an answer for one of the
quiz questions I believe uh if you want
to learn more about what I've been
talking about you can uh check our blog
where uh we write in more detail and
there's also a pre-int available on this
on
archive and yeah that's what I wanted to
share with you uh today
[Applause]
yeah